No good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
delighted to welcome all of you here and
to all of us who are watching online to
our friends in the press what a honor
and delight it is for me to host Jamie
Dimon who's sitting here to my right as
all of you know he's the CEO and
chairman of JPMorgan Chase he oversees
it's funny you know there are days when
I feel sort of feeling sorry for myself
because I have 280 employees and a
budget of 50 million dollars jamie has
250,000 employees and 200 and 2.5
trillion dollars in assets I will never
complain again he is an entrepreneur who
has truly you know in bodies the spirit
of something we talk about a lot in AEI
which is to live a startup life you know
the essence of entrepreneurship is
understanding your life as an enterprise
he started by selling greeting cards at
the age of six and by the age of 40 was
one of the preeminent chief executives
in the United States a place where he's
remained and and enhanced his reputation
not just as somebody who's a visionary
in business but also somebody who's a
true idea person a man who understands
policy and wants to bring better ideas
to policy things he learns in business
and things that he observes around the
country this we're gonna be talking
about today so delighted to have you
Jamie welcome to our stage in the new
AEI building thank you for having me
here thank you you know a lot of people
here and we can't see the people who are
watching us online but we've a big
audience online and a lot of people have
been very interested in your a lot of
the things that you're doing because
you're spending more time in Washington
DC why are you coming to Washington so
often these days well first I always
came to Washington remember I have my
regulators down here which I have many
and obviously we do stuff in the Senate
and his best friends and the
administration they also became the
chairman the Business Roundtable
oh yeah so which is a - one of the
largest companies in America it's an
advocacy group around policy you know
immigration trade taxation corporate
governance work skills initiatives and I
agreed to do the Act think it's really
important for the future of America we
get those policies right so the the BRT
the business round
is not something that people typically
associate with policy they think of it
as an industry trade group to promote
the the needs and interests of business
per se you do see it differently why do
you see it as a policy yeah because
member industry further there's like
with 7,000 lobby groups here and in this
town it's like 7 million I think
everybody and but and the fact is every
group has its own so life insurance has
its own you know manufactures their own
motion pictures has its own but this one
is the purpose is broad public policy
taxation immigration trade smart
regulation corporate governance things
which I think are very good for the
future of America is very good for
growing it and we try to be not
parochial so we're not trying to fight
for Bank regulations I've never spoken
to group about and everything about bank
regulation on those other policies
what's good for America why we should
get those policies done how we can get
to get them over the hill so tell me
what are the big policy issues that are
front of mine for you today and I'm
gonna walk through a whole bunch of them
but tell me the one that's keeping you
awake at night the most what's give me
up no I I'm gonna put immigration on
that but I think it's kind of tearing us
apart mm-hmm I think we'd be growing
faster would be a happier nation I think
most Americans actually agree you know
we should have merit-based
if you get an advanced degree here you
get to stay some pants the citizenship
for law-abiding taxpaying undocumented
and I think most Americans actually grew
with that we need border security I
think a statement that we haven't really
had good border security I don't know
what that means a wall I'm not an expert
but I think the American public needs
bull we have good border security and
the last one I say is cultural there's
this kind of fear in America that
immigrants are coming here to change
America not coming here to be American
so you know my grandparents are
immigrants I'm sure a lot of people here
your grandparents great-grandparents
immigrants they came here to be American
they you know they've learned American
history they learned the Pledge of
Allegiance they learned about America as
an idea of freedom freedom of speech
freedom of enterprise from a religion it
was not a tribe you know it wasn't and
that is an important thing and we
violate that a little bit not a lot so
if we get it fixed we'll be happier
people you're a lot happier Americans
and we'll have a faster growing economy
and we're going to need the workers by
the way if you look at the workforce we
know we don't have enough workers to
fill some of these jobs anymore
tell me what what your grandfather
your grandfather diamond did when he
came the United States yeah my
grandfather well he's like everybody
else he he didn't finish high school
I'll be getting my grandparents finished
high school they may have been
undocumented for I know but he you know
worked as a dishwasher he went to move
to degree I'm Greek Greek part of town
you know he only only taught English in
school so he had to learn English pretty
quickly and he kind of worked his way up
and he eventually started working at a
bank and he became a VP at the bank and
after World War two he went to become a
stockbroker mmm my father became a
stockbroker it kind of would pique my
interest in in financial markets etc and
and he's great man so the reason I asked
that question is because you know that's
the I mean look around this room and we
see a hundred different immigrant
stories here they're all different
you know scratching out a living in
Greece and in your case or you know
running from a pogrom in the case of a
lot of my colleagues here at AEI or or
in some of the cases is being brought to
this country and voluntarily but what
everybody has in common is that they're
they came from ambitious riffraff yeah
that's the American experience so do we
really want more of a merit-based system
we just want more people that are
destroyers oh you want a merit-based
system too we I think the number is
300,000 kids come here from around the
world they get degrees and our great
universities and advanced degrees and we
fundamentally make them go home and I
think you agree with me we should give
all the green card they that is sending
brains overseas that kind of wants to
stay here and you see happening now the
people building in R&D centers in
Vancouver and Toronto because of very
kids who educated here can't work here
so you know some of these companies are
putting their research centers and
trying to and I just don't know why we
wouldn't grow up a little bit in that
it's any brains overseas as a bad idea
just like I put corporate taxes which
was fixed corporate separate the
individual okay I think people have to
understand the corporate taxes we need a
competitive tax system to have a
competitive economy period the notion
you have a very uncompetitive tax system
in this global world of ours is wrong
and so that we were driving a lot of
companies overseas and capital overseas
and plants overseas not everybody but a
lot of those who can choose we're doing
that and on the individual side you can
argue what we should have done you know
and so with the business community get
involved in that part of the fight but
competive taxes to me that's the center
corn on for
the economy so we're talking about
capital flows we started with labor
flows and before before before we leave
that subject is it fair to say that
you're pretty critical and concerned
with the way that the country is turned
with respect to immigration policy but
more importantly about immigration
culture yeah I think the culture is an
issue you know and I I hope president
Trump but I've been with President Trump
he says I want to do the green cards I
want to find I want doctor to stay he
also says but you know I want the wall
and you know so that's the politics of
immigration you know I'm not that it's
in the politics I think we should treat
the 12 million people here who were who
were taxpaying and law-abiding properly
path to citizenship it's a long path
they have to basically at the end of the
line you know giving legal status keep
Doctor Doom eridan I think would just be
a better nation guest-worker program
absolutely uh-huh okay so let's get back
to tax reform we just started on that
and that's a path that we do need to go
down it's been six or seven months since
we had tax reform in this country it was
a happy day around 80 I in no small part
because a lot of the ideas that when to
the tax reform legislation were hatched
by economists here at AEI the politics
of it resulted in a pretty complicated
piece of legislation you were on net Pro
right oh no I was a pro tax reform and
why do you weigh me the most because it
was Drive all of these if you had a
choice so some people have been on
national TV saying it didn't affect any
business decisions I make that's true if
you're an American only company it
didn't basically fundamentally affect
your decisions it gave you less capital
to reinvest but if you are a large
company and you have a choice to invest
in a plant overseas or plant here at 20
percent tax rate you had a 50 percent
higher return okay and there are studies
that one of the big accounting firms did
that estimated 5000 companies large to
small so now told big companies net are
now owned by overseas companies because
advantageous for a couple overseas to
own that company here so the
headquarters now overseas that's a bad
idea
so my point is had a competitive tax
system you'll have the best economy and
the benefit and the other thing you hear
about all the time is which I agree with
part of part of the benefit was
immediate you did see people raise wages
cut medical deductibles and now some new
investments and branches which we did
you know 40 new branches including
you're coming to
we want all your accounts by the way
they got the best stuff no small
business small business lending for
entrepreneurs of color so we did that a
lot of companies did it but the real
benefit is the retention of capital
reinvested in the United States over
time and that's a cumulative effect okay
and you're going to see some of that
over time and you know the can't you'll
never know exactly the counterfactuals
but the thing I strongly disagree with
is this this refrain this narrative that
comes out that they're just doing
thought buybacks and dividends capital
is the kind of thing that if you can't
use it you would turn it to your
shareholder it doesn't disappear the
shareholder reuses it they may invest in
a venture thing they may invest in a
company they may go buy a house but in
any event it's like a free QE it's not
from the government it's our own money
recirculating the economy and so it's a
good thing though we don't know what the
immediate effect that is but the real
long-term cumulative effect is hugely
positive on the individual side they
eliminated you know state and local I
know you probably in Washington don't
like that your Massachusetts New York
Illinois or California but everybody
else likes it the and the thing about
state local 80% of the benefit went to
people make it over five hundred
thousand dollars a year they did the
right thing to get rid of it I'm sorry
and all my friends in New York I've
furiously me all the time for saying
this and now I would have done things
differently an individual so I probably
would have not reduced taxes and people
like me I would have tax carried
interest I would have died double the
Earned Income Tax Credit to make you
know a low-skilled job more of a living
wage to give people the dignity of a job
the ability to do more of that and so I
might have done something differently in
the individual side but absolutely we
needed to competitive tax reform I would
also do an infrastructure is another one
and now we put a man on the moon in
eight years and now takes twelve years
and I don't consider this funny though
you're all gonna laugh to get the
permits to build a bridge that's the
can-do nation of America
so our highways bridges tunnels airports
we are getting old it nailed by most the
Conner's estimates as cost as more money
not to fix it than to fix it we created
this huge regulatory burden to get
permits and build bridges and if we
don't fix it it's hurting us and again
the estimates I say point two point
three percent of your GDP so one of my
big things I think the reason our anemic
growth was so slow is because of
our decisions it wasn't it doesn't have
to be slow it wasn't a secular
stagnation it was immigration taxation
infrastructure education the opioid
crisis which we have to do be much more
aggressive in fixing lots to talk about
that's you know you're traveling around
United States all the time you're
talking to given the fact that your
business is so cross-hatched with
community banks and smaller banks and
and and of course the rest of the
economy that relies on banking you
predicted before tax reform that it was
going to have a stimulatory impact on
downstream on lots and lots of
businesses do you see it yeah I mean
it's kind of anecdotal but when I travel
around to small businesses middle market
companies large companies most of them
not all of them most say we have seen
will regulatory reform and we're doing
more stuff we're building this this road
we're building this pipeline when I'm
opening a new store so yeah we have seen
it and you see it and there's another
place by the way consumer and business
confidence skyrocketed but then
skyrocketed everyone loves the president
skyrockets people are pro-business
pro-capital pro-growth and pro
regulatory reform and one is the word
regulatory reform meaning killed a
bureaucracy okay the bureaucracy we have
allowed the some of these regulatory
bureaucratic things to really slow down
or our thing think of the DMV think of
the VA well that's what's happened that
would happen to business so small
business formation in this recovery was
the lowest it's ever been okay and and
it could be in the order of a million
small business at this point so we you
know that we should acknowledge the
things we that we did to hurt ourselves
and fix them and these issues by the way
to me have nothing to with Democrats
Republicans does it have to do with
practical thoughtful policy that works
now you said something I want to come
back to for a minute which is about you
said there were dignity and something
you feel strongly about as we all do and
the key thing that you and I have talked
about the past is that dignity comes
from work dignity comes from the purpose
and meaning that come from being needed
through a real job tell me what we need
to do in this country to actually get
more people into not into fake jobs not
into make work jobs into real jobs in
the real economy so they can support
themselves in their family so I believe
in healthy safety social net for the
we needed an old poor disabled etc and
our son but I also believe that a lot of
it and we do is transfer payment so a
lot of them that doesn't necessary and
so a lot of the folks who would prefer
to have a job your people the the common
notions the job is bad most people have
jobs like their jobs they've learned you
know they've learned how to do things
you know if that we diminish like the
burger flippers well that's the person's
start a job and they go to the second
job if you go to most the fast-food
places the assistant managers and the
manager started that way and they're
proud of what they did to themselves so
I agree we got to get the kids job so
how do you get jobs a healthy economy so
focus on how you grow the economy
you can always tax people differently
but focus on the things that grow the
economy and then skills so the skills
take place at high school so there's a
high school they're high schools all
around which do this kids
learn they go to high school but they
also learn how to maintain a car they
leave forty five thousand dollars a year
and they're quite happy okay they could
still go into college so whether with
this high schools community colleges etc
preparing kids for jobs and there are
lots of jobs out there the nursing
codine maintaining equipment logistics
supply a custom customer service you
know sales is a job you can learn how to
be a good at sales or something like
that and so we don't do a good job again
Americans be one of the best of that
plumbers electricians vocational schools
community colleges and we've lost our
way for and against a lot of
bureaucratic reasons you know like a lot
of people teach these schools it's all
about college you know in college has
its huge benefit but but like you know
the unemployment rate is I think in
Spain and Italy for men 20 to 30 or
something like that it's like 15 to 20
percent okay and Switzerland is 2
percent mm-hmm because of Switzerland
these kids go on to learn a skill with
real paid apprenticeships that work for
the businesses and work for the kids
they can still going to college okay so
something like 70% do that and 30% go to
college is not that different you have
the United States and they're just do a
better job at getting people involved in
the workforce and every time we get kids
and we go to inner-city schools where
there's problems called TFI we go to
industry schools we do this with
already men not women who were in
trouble the kids who may not make it out
they have problems with family that
probably education and we started this
program we give him a mentor
apprenticeships training to get him into
college and to get him through college
and I've been to I've been to one of
those graduations you know in the path
of that usually a single parent buts is
crying when the kids come to Princeton
Harvard or one of those and and they
have dignity they you know they you know
they always tell you they didn't know
like working it can be be fun they
didn't know that like executives make
jokes they thought it can be like a very
militaristic thing to be really
unpleasant all day long and it's not
most people like going to work mmm it's
like work is like the office in a
comedic comedy show you know it's we do
have a few yuxin yeah what one thing
that a little bit of data that
reinforces your point is that you know
most people think that they enjoy their
jobs but they assume that most other
people don't like their jobs the but the
truth is that eighty-nine percent of
Americans alike or love their jobs and
that does not depend on college
attainment and it does not depend on
income which means that it is sort of
disrespectful to say that poor people's
work is somehow a punishment and poor
people's work is somehow a bunch of junk
jobs the first rung in the ladder is
still part of ladder is I think your
basic point you also here's the best job
training these young kids know the
military yeah right they shave them they
teach them teamwork show up in time or
just as communications and there and
when they get out of the military
they're all proud and they know what to
do they want to work as part of a team
you know this does the second best job
McDonald's same thing and they have that
great commercial on TV now so if you
hear me Steve I'm bragging on you but
you know that great camera is saying the
best first job I mean and it could be
because it is that first wrong I like
that shaving them part we're gonna start
out that ie I I hired a barber the so
okay so when we talk about the military
or McDonald's and and you're talking a
lot about skills you know you care
you're passionate about as a matter of
fact vocational technical education may
be a national apprenticeship program
wouldn't be fantastic their point is
everybody needs more skills well they
come out of high school but I think that
we both agree that not everybody needs
college yeah one of the biggest problems
that we have is this college for all
mentality notwithstanding the fact that
it's fantastic
so an amazing leg up for so many people
but I know you and I talked about this
in the past that too many people go to
college because the field I have - as
opposed to going to work and we have a
society that rewards college that should
be rewarding skills and experience so
here's my question
you have 250,000 employees what could
you do to show the rest of the country
that people can earn their success
through hard work and personal
responsibility and merit and skills
training without going to college
so here's a mistake I think we made and
I think a lot of companies make because
it's easy for us to do college degree
required so it's like a screen and it
makes sense that makes a lot of sense
but a college degree is not required for
a lot of things that you do in a call
center of teller and when you start as a
call center tell doesn't mean you can't
go to college later it just means you
have a choice and and there's this it
may be true by the way that the kids go
to college they become a teller we have
high attrition because that's not what
they aspired to do and then you've got
the college kid the high school kid we
did this program - in New York City my
wife did it so if you're watching Judy
thank you we trade these high school
kids and they love these jobs and the
jobs paid $35,000 with full medical and
retirement you know and and which is
worth $12,000 a year and so these kids
feel great about it and of course we I
expect them to go on through something
else later in their life they have to do
that but you know that someone might
move up become bankers in the branch
branch managers regional directors hell
they may get to my job one day
mmm-hmm great and so if you think of
American companies made a commitment
that was less toward using calls as a
signal and more toward figuring out what
skills people need we could actually
create the demand signals that would go
to the American education system and I
think it was an accidental mistake that
was made that should be fixed and a lot
of companies are realizing this by the
way and the BRT is done a whole study
and work skills and issues and this is
to come at many times the other issue by
the way is we have 20 million stones in
this country and and you know a lot of
them deserve to have a second chance I'm
not talking about violent you know
offenders but a lot of the things that
are written in the laws people would
hire them hmm I can't get credit I can't
get a job how do you get a second chance
and so we have to do a better job giving
you know these folks a chance and so
we've you know and for a bank there will
actually kind of regulations it's
essentially said you can't hire felons
and we've actually got them to change
that and that we will now try of
programs and certain jobs ex non vine
felons maybe can get a job somewhere
they're maybe not Willie Sutton but yeah
but specifically not really so yeah
that's they so it's it you bring up the
the criminal justice system we were just
talking about unnecessary ecology you
you have given me a list in the past of
this very interesting list that I think
we want to share with the audience here
you know people will talk about the ways
to increase GDP the GDP stimulators the
easy ones you have a list of negative
GDP stimulators in other words the
things that actually are lowering
economic productivity and growth in this
country
so take through I'm going to tick
through them and yeah and also like
economists don't normally put these in
models and most of these have gotten
worse over time
so therefore they you know they've been
static the whole time they may not
actually reduce the GDP we spent a lot
of money in war like trillions okay
which obviously has a huge effect on
productivity negatively the
uncompetitive tax system the bed
education system the increasing
inability to build infrastructure the
increasing regulations was you know if
don't think about big banks think about
small businesses and bureaucracy and
stuff like that that stops small
business formation the opioid priors the
felon crisis I'm sure I'm missing
something I had a list of ten all are
negative productivity factors and the
reason the reason you start thinking
about it is if I travel the country and
you know all the business people here
how many of you are getting the
productivity of two percent almost every
businesses and just started me thinking
well how come is not higher and it may
very well be because of bad policy and
we need to fix these things and again
they're not Democrat Republican and they
need to be fixed in a lot of these cases
business working with government civic
society to come with solutions and
execute something actually makes sense
and you see it happening on a city level
mayor Duggan in Detroit is doing it okay
Mitch Landrieu in a New Orleans did it
okay Rahm Emanuel in Chicago did it
where they actually changing things at
the ground working with business schools
how they do the jobs to help make their
might their economy work better so a lot
of the experiments that happen the city
and are working fallows who wrote
that are great articles antic they were
traveled around in went to small
Midwestern companies and was kind of
surprised to find out how many are
thriving the opposite of what you
thought and hit was anecdotal be much
like fifty cities and he started to say
why it was usually because the mayor
only cared about how the city not
necessary the next job the business
people want to help the city the Civic
people want to help the city and they
came with ideas to help
let's bring in this business let's clean
up this park let's have a night program
for the kids let's let's put some more
money in the hospital let's do and it
works and so that's I hope our
government we start to collaborate
little bit more like that and we'll have
successful solutions for a lot of these
problems
look let me let me push back on one area
because I want to get your thinking on
this one of the things that it's always
amazed me is the fact that when I
contemplate the fact that the the
greatest source of growth in Asia has
been of course has been globalization
and free trade China for example has
pulled 600 million people out of
starvation level poverty since 1980
extraordinary that has everything to do
with with trade with the rest of the
world a good deal of it with the United
States why has that been facilitated
because for the very first time the sea
lanes in the Pacific have been free of
war and the number one reason that these
sea lanes have been free of pugilistic
forces is because of the American blue
water Navy in other words its American
military force which is not a deadweight
loss in this in this context on the
contrary its stimulated growth beyond
the wildest imaginations of American
consumers but beyond that has pulled
hundreds of millions of people at a
starvation level poverty around the
world so to what extent can we net out
the the deadweight costs of conflict
versus something like this you know the
military is is an unbelievable
institution if anyone served here thank
you all right but you're absolutely
correct you know PAC's Americana is much
more appreciated around the world it is
here an America did a lot of things for
for not just economic reason but for
moral reason it's still the one country
that does things to help other people
and it's not trying to steal their oil
or their land or things like that so PAX
America is important trade is important
so trade and technology have lifted
billions of out of poverty and well I
think there are really legitimate
complaints about trade particularly
around China okay we shouldn't throw the
bay out of the bath water here and and
the American leadership is also really
important to maintain
you know a really healthy global economy
so let's stay on shredder for a second
your China bull right generally yes tell
me about that you know China you gotta
be I say this respectfully okay America
has all the food water and energy needs
very peaceful neighbors Canada Mexico we
haven't had a worth either one
since the mexican-american war in 1848
hey China does not have enough food war
and energy its neighbors are really
tough Russia Vietnam India Pakistan
Afghanistan Korea Indonesia Philippines
Japan who are quite worried about China
by the way and so they and they still
have 400 million people living in
poverty they don't have our institutions
they don't have a rule of law they have
very high corruption levels that's why
they have to elbows market reform but
the leadership starting you know 30
years ago started to look at what the
rest of the world was doing like
Singapore in particular at this time and
said well we could do that and lift up
our people you know they they're the the
so they had a long way to go as much
easy to start your economy from to grow
it to ten thousand from $60 a person the
10th out of GDP and so they're quite
smart they want to lift up their people
I should any leadership of any country
that they were very thoughtful about it
they've built institutions education
they started reform markets reform like
they they would die to have our market
reform and the innovation and growth and
local eruption and high transparence we
have in this country it just can be a
long time get there so this isn't like
they're gonna win automatically they
have to do a lot to get even close to
having the prosperous economy we have
here today now where we shoot ourselves
in the foot sometimes and they're they
since they can Mac will manage they can
take decisions that are very hard to
take a democracy and they have huge
issues to overcome pouring out the
democracy
eliminating corruption clean and more
efficient economy think of the
state-owned enterprises I do think the
better out the more likely outcomes of
30 years from now they will have 40
percent of the Fortune 1000 they already
have 20 percent they're graduating I
think five times or 10 times more stem
students here than we do you know
they're sending a couple thousand
students around the year and paying for
it bringing them back so they have a
more educated population the odds are
they'll do quite well and but the one
didn't have serious bumps in the road
it won't be like the last 20 years
whether you know had 10 percent growth
of any stumbles they may
very lot of stumbles like the
restaurants ahead so how would you
manage our trade relationship with China
today given all the things that you've
just said and and and given the fact we
have obviously there are some
difficulties with it right now BRT has
spoken to the administration and the
president directly myself directly
sometimes about the issues and you hear
about them but this thing is much more
detailed tariffs non-tariff barriers are
just regulated or stopping things in law
that you get the right to do it but
there's no way you can get this thing
shipped in and you know if the
non-reciprocal investment ownership we
can't buy a hundred percent of you know
a broker dealer over there they could
buy a hundred percent over dealer here
that's true for a hundred industries by
the way and then I think it's a little
overblown so they don't enterprises and
support so they have this industrial
policy you know it's nothing really
heavy industrial policy but the fear is
they're using their money subsidies to
the standard enterprise to dominate
global industries that would be a
problem so if that's true that will be a
huge problem so our view is a huge issue
the president raised it we would have
done it differently so the method is
different you know our view is you just
have seriously you should have gotten
Mexico Canada Japan Europe which they
may be doing now Korea have a common
view of how the world trade systems
change a little bit and then go see
Korea not nasty and not against them
saying this is the standard which all up
--have we should update WTO which update
IP laws we should update state-owned
enterprise laws etc some of which are
not dealt with in the WTO okay so the
predecessor rights a WTO is is
antiquated it is so let's fix it but I
think we thought it'd be better than
tariffs and the fear of tariffs was
always that it would be tit for tat
which is very predictable and it just
creates the chance that something goes
south but you know I hope it works and
the president said it worked in getting
NAFTA done and god bless him we've
wanted a NAFTA deal we wanted the deal
to get done you know how you get it done
and you know obviously the method might
be different so but it seems like he's
now gets trying to get the ducks in a
row with the other partners before he
goes to China which is what I would do
and then be just very honest with China
tell them what you want how you want it
when you want it listen to what they
have to say like in any negotiation and
come up with something works for both
parties so you're you are
optimistic about the trade policy with
China the way that it's going so far
that you've seen I am optimistic I think
the odds of a policy error are higher
when nations start to get angry at each
other so therefore you know the the
indirect effect of confidence capital
stuff like that could actually mount and
we know reverse some of benefit we've
seen from tax reform regulatory reform
but but I don't know I mean it's just
it's a different way to go about
something and I hope he succeeds yeah
and you also are more in favor of
multilateral trade agreements as opposed
to the bilateral approach the
president's taking are you you could do
either and make them good so I'm not for
one or the other so obviously multi loud
I can do a great deal with you but I'm
by Lao but multilateral can do the same
thing because you know you're giving
away and you know what you're getting so
whatever I give you and maybe give them
the ten people but I'm getting I'm
getting from ten people and since you so
be slightly different deals there might
be less complex than happy to do ten
separate ones and we put them all
together I'm not sure you're better off
with worse off I'm gonna change a little
bit we've been talking about policies in
terms of any piece of geopolitical it
wasn't just the trade policy it was
America and its allies setting kind of
how commerce should take place with
standards that we walls all believe in
around some of the rules I just talked
about some humanity standards some
pollution standards and so I think it
would've been good and maybe one day
they'll revisit it so how long you been
CEO well I became CEO of Bank one in
2000
JPMorgan I wasn't see a CEO for 18
months so Oh since 2000 18 years - 18
months okay and you've had every year
more employees and a more complex
organization you've seen a lot in the
policy environment you've seen a lot of
disagreement let's give some advice from
arguably America's most successful CEO
to Washington DC which is not very which
is not not getting along at the moment
let's talk a little bit about how you
have actually been able to find
cooperation and consensus and a highly
combat of environment which is the
banking sector in a very large and
complex organization what are some
principles of leadership that washington
needs to learn from corporate america I
wish the old Washington's I think and
think of those not kind words
look my my view it look I run JPMorgan
Chase and so we goes
everybody all the time you know and I've
never said well I don't like them I
don't like this one policy to have we
got to see them we see presidents and
prime ministers and ministers of finance
around the world and just try to have a
conversation understand their point of
view you know tell me if you think with
the wrong or why sometimes every now and
then they say something is really smart
and you go back and check and there's a
better way to do it so very all we try
to be very open with everybody we have a
lot of really good people involved in
policy
you gotta in a democracy that democracy
is tough you know the politicians I know
what my job is no politics by their
nature have to compromise that is what a
democracy is say okay I don't want to
put that highway there but I'll put it
there if you build the school I really
need there's nothing wrong with that
there is no other way that is what a
democracy is you got it and that's what
they try to do in Congress I think when
they become very partisan it stops good
policy I don't care that the partisan I
care that we're not getting the good
positive sure it's the average American
and it hurts the average American much
more than hurts me and so you know to me
it's like we should find common ground I
think people should have dinner together
I think they should you know I even in
my company I tell you know go take
people out to lunch that you're not
comfortable with someone have a
different color you know and some of it
and so find out what it is they believe
and you know have those conversations to
do the best you can don't get angry you
know what most people have their own
they are in I think are in the interest
of what they want the United States of
America nothing happens our
collaboration almost nothing and the the
bad part is you often see when the
government does something which 100%
partisan you subject the country to 20
years of war okay that was Obamacare 10
years of war you know other policies it
really if you can't do certain things
bipartisan you shouldn't do them at all
and wait for a better time and so I want
universal health care for Americans I
think there are ways to get it and to do
it that makes sense on my list twenty
percent of our GDP and health care okay
the rest of the developing world is
around ten percent and that is a huge
problem and it's going to it's gonna
break our budget in 10 or 20 years it's
gonna and and so to me that's another
negative productivity when all nobody is
good if you live longer you know
medicine help me of course is better but
a lot of it isn't better outcomes
it's fraud it's waste it's waste of
end-of-life it's it's we don't do
wellness programs obesity is driving
cancer stroke heart disease depression
and we got to fix these things and so I
put that in my negative productivity
list too it's great thing you know gave
me an AI because you know one of the
things here is that all conversations
wind up being about policy I mean I
could start a conversation about the
dental plan at ATI that we'd wind up
talking about dental policy which is a
fantastic thing and you notice that
every question I ask keeps coming back
to policy you're a national policy guy
yeah yeah after this you should be a
scholar day yeah
so okay now there's polarization in
Washington you already dealt with that
but this polarization around the country
one in six Americans have stopped
talking to a close friend or family
member over politics 40% of both
Democrats and Republicans say that they
would be deeply unhappy if their child
married a member of the other party and
as recently as 1980 that was about 6% or
did you get these numbers hey I'm all
numbers man so that's a and so okay
so now let's just say that that's absurd
absolutely it's what an alternative the
universe your president United States
what would you do to turn down the
temperature on our political
disagreements and bring America to the
harmony that we need to make the new
American Century
someone told me that President Obama had
never had Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell
over for lunch or dinner I would have
him every week that's it
every week and I wouldn't make it
personal and yes they're not going to
agree in a whole bunch of things they
don't like each other's choices and
stuff like that and and I don't know
what the and you guys are better at this
and I am but gerrymandering maybe we
should have open primaries I was never a
favorite term lose I've kind of changed
my mind
Attorney General should not be allowed
to run for governor for four years after
office because they used that job for
personal professional purposes and so I
think there are fixes that we need to
have to do and maybe it's in financing
of parties and disclosures of parties
and I we wouldn't have to do something
because this really doesn't work you
know I've had two more questions for you
that I'm going to turn over to the
audience and that my my penultimate
question is about what you've learned
over the past ten years it was it was a
tricky time in 2000
in your industry and and and you you you
personally had to do a lot of things as
a CEO that you probably didn't envision
when you when you started at your career
what have you learned over the past ten
years and how has it changed you as a
leader I'm not I'm not sure I've learned
that much you know a lot a lot of the
lessons are like you know that's bad no
no lately markets just shifted what he
said no I'm saying that there certainly
I'd say I might advise my Chairman's
like certain lessons they weren't
learned there re learned like you've put
them over and over it's like if you
learn a box you hold up your hands yeah
well you learn when you get in the ring
and the guy punches it face 15 times
their own row and then you hold up your
hands and and so so diligence hardwork
morality do the right thing those well I
always believe in them you know and but
I haven't I haven't changed as a person
I probably been much more time on policy
teaching strategy than I did you know
just the detail nuts and bolts of
systems up you know competitors and
stuff like that most leagues have a
great management team and I don't have
to do some of those things anymore so uh
so when you started your career you're
doing more on changing management
systems and now you're thinking more at
the meta level about the policies that
affect your industry we're growing and
we're doing a whole bunch of stuff we
have new products have served open our
first branch in the chase
you know May I went to see Mayor Doug it
may have Duggan's the guy you know who
grew up the we need venture capital for
entrepreneurs of color they can't get
they don't have normal bank financing
and they don't have the same fallback
capital they get from family and it was
a great idea we worked on it we came up
with one we start with a four million
dollar fund is now a twenty million
dollar fund we're now doing it not just
in Detroit but in Chicago New Orleans in
New York and you know if this really
works well it's lifting up a lot of
people why not a billion dollars and of
course when you travel around and listen
you get ideas for everybody who thought
of Mayor was going to teach us about
financing small business but he did and
so you know about Steve cases sure
worries yeah yeah yeah he finds out that
Steve Case our friend who he's been at
you have many times that 75% of venture
capital goes to three states California
New York and Massachusetts and and about
two percent one and a half percent goes
to Pennsylvania well Pennsylvania's got
these two huge cities and
lots of towns in between a melon with
all dar but and this is a he but this is
not a tragedy this is an opportunity and
this is something that you've emphasized
and I'm for when I've interviewed you or
when we've spoken in the past that in in
the key things it seems to meet a
leadership lesson from Jamie Dimon is
look at all of the bad things that are
going on that's your opportunity set
yeah is that right
also policy yeah now we're coming in as
a microcosm we're coming to DC so it's
not just we're here in investment
banking or a bank the government's we're
here in commercial banking or even
private banking the regulators for
somebody didn't want to open retail
branches but we've opened these retail
branches it would serve i think there'd
be fifty up to seventy you're talking
about took about five hundred jobs
directly another thousand indirectly but
in the in those branches small business
lending entrepreneurs we're going to put
some of the branches in Ward 6 and 7 7 &
8 so we're gonna try some special
financial education so those branches
we're gonna do small business lending
affordable housing lending but do more
philanthropy because we're here on the
ground now and yeah you helped lift up a
community if we do a good job you can
help lift up Washington DC mm-hmm
last question before we turn over to the
audience so get your questions ready so
you've seen a lot in the last 18 years
CEO and in a long career even before
that every executive has every leader
has made mistakes and has learned from
those mistakes tell me the biggest
mistake that you think that you've made
as a leader and what you learn from it
which I makes I've made so many that's
amazing okay and if I write a book one
of the books I should write which would
be my biggest mistakes it'll be a long
volume and but you learn so I'm gonna
tell you the nature of the mistakes made
and the mistakes any decision made at
anger is wrong yeah don't get angry I
don't yell live stuff like that but if
you get that welling up inside of you
and you say I'm not doing that you're
probably making a mistake any decision
made on a Friday when you're tired is
wrong any decision the the eggs Fridays
off now yeah but the biggest mistake is
I don't you don't have the right people
in the room the chance of making a
mistake you know I don't sit then I
guess sometimes I get we get relaxed
might be able to work the issue we work
at work at work it and you're much more
likely to make a better outcome you get
the right people in the room and work it
these there are solutions
work it work in a second time work with
a third time so and obviously the
biggest mistake of all is when you have
wrong people and when you didn't
thoroughly vet the person or you gave
them responsibility they were entitled
to that hurts you your company more than
anything else and that's a multi-year
setback it takes it takes a while to
figure out who they are I always tell
people [ __ ] pretty good at
bullshitting you know it some of them
practice for 25 years you know and and
but you get a pretty good radar for it
but and then if there they are and then
you know it takes a while before people
tell you Jamie this this is not working
and that's made could be another year
and it takes another happy to find
someone that's two and a half years of
damage done lost time and so you know
the biggest one is be thorough on how
you people and I learned and I maybe to
know each other longer don't necessarily
promote people that you wouldn't work
for if you wouldn't have your kid work
for the person or if you wouldn't want
to work for the person yourself why are
you giving the bigger job and yet
there's this huge temptation under the
best salesmen that are best this they've
been patting their chests or quote they
deserve it they've been there long
enough they deserve and that's a
terrible thing because very often it's
not true so you have to be very thorough
on job promotions hiring stuff like that
so people are everything obviously in
banking people are everything but people
are everything every place in life
people are everything because
relationships are what matter the mostly
the ultimate the ultimate resource
what's the bigger mistake is that hiring
the wrong people or not or not parting
ways quickly enough when you realize
somebody is the wrong person oh when you
make one you tend to at least the other
and being blind you know we interview
people now we have a lot of people
interview them know sometimes I mean I
may be good at what I do buy may not be
the best interviewers I'm I really like
you I love talking to you instead of
saying can you do the job
ya know some of these jobs are big tough
job front to back it's like running a
big machine and you think the person
might be good at it they're not but
they're gonna be good at is empathy jobs
you know as sales or covering people or
policy jobs and research there's nothing
wrong with that but you make mistakes
like that and it's hard but over time
you get much better I mean we have
exceptional people I'm when I travel the
world and we have seen your country
offices in six or 50 countries we've got
investment bankers who are respected by
the clients we've got retail banks if I
go in and the client says tell me how
great the branch manager is
our branch has served doggie bones two
dogs you know people go just to get the
doggy bone for their dog and someone
said Jim you could save money baby we're
the doggie boys and when I get rid of
doggie bones the dogs likes them
therefore their orders like them and you
know people people visit the branch just
sometimes for companionship and so you
know but inside the company every branch
manager every receptionist every banker
know the better they are the better is
for everybody and part is to have the
honesty cleaning it up people tell each
other the truth so you don't have this
you know a lot of companies they have
politics the enemy is the person next to
you not the competitor so this is an
important thing to having the energy
doing the right stuff as opposed the
energy doing their own stuff I'm gonna
turn it over to our friends here
obviously I heard go for the rest of the
time but that would be the wrong thing
to do we've got mics and we'll come out
and we've got first hand I saw it was
right here in the center aisle we got
right one right behind you sir you can
stand up and tell us who you are and we
can you know I Luke or do with accordion
associates and I appreciate your comment
earlier that not everyone needs a
college degree but I suspect that your
mid and upper level managers do have
degrees so the question is do you have a
company program that helps them your
employees get a better education while
they're working for you yeah we have we
have tuition assistance and programs
like that we also spend I forgot the
number but a billion dollars you're
trained our own people so you know you
look at these big institutions we bring
in 40,000 people a year we train 40,000
people a year we probably chain another
40,000 to move up to another job we send
them back to school we give them medical
benefits I took we give them Pilates and
massages that makes them happy you know
we do all these things and we pay them
well are you our lowest starting wages
of generally 16 dollars and so these and
I'm not just be for my company we do why
are you doing the massages by the way I
know you personally I've always said
that your I always said that as a joke
and I walked into our headquarters the
other day it was Employee Appreciation
Week and there were like 50 people
giving massages to our employees and
maybe they might have done that stuff to
make me I'm not a liar but I mean I'm
saying we want to take care of our
people we move around the world we take
care of their families they give full
benefits to them and so we go out of our
way and tuition assistance is one of
them
here the back yes ma'am good afternoon
I'm Karen Alston I'm an entrepreneur I
own two businesses and I'm gonna ask the
question but first I have to say that
you need to add JP Morgan to that list
because I came straight out of undergrad
to work for JP Morgan on Wall Street and
end up in private client it was the best
training I've ever received and it
helped me with my career going forward
thank you and tonight I'm attending a
black female founders dinner that JP
Morgan is hosting here Tracy so here I
wasn't doing so I would have gone to
that guy look what those things are so
much fun and you learn a lot I'm so
excited for it thank you thank you for
doing that
so we're ten years out of the financial
crisis and I wanted to get your feedback
on that but more importantly we're at a
place where more hedge funds are owning
our traditional corporations and I
wanted to hear your thoughts on the
hedge fund industry buying more
traditional corporations and what that
means for the American worker so put
this on your list and negative
productivity is is the things that are
going on in corporate governance I
believe in good corporate governance
transparency openness active boards and
stuff like that but we've gone from
8,000 public companies to 4,000 public
companies and I'm gonna put on the list
of why that is and again people study
this and I don't know exactly
capricious and arbitrary litigation
being in the public eye means you're
constantly being attacked by various
entities and and stuff like that
frivolous shareholder meeting so we have
look I love my shareholders I speak to
them in various forms all the time
but the show the meeting has become a
farce that's what it is we all know that
and and you know social groups take I'm
not against social groups but you know
they get hijacked by that so a lot of
people are going don't want to go public
and then obviously regulations and all
those things they've changed some of
those things so I think having public
companies is a good thing now in some
cases okay private businesses you can
get money longer I think hedge funds and
private equity are like other businesses
some are good some are bad there's a bit
in the marketplace for companies they've
their doctors they fix them no different
and we try to do so it could be good or
bad so I talk for me to say that but I
think it's bad that were driving them
private and I think we should look at
these things and particularly litigation
and our litigation stuff you know is
probably the most expensive one in the
world
and it's arbitrary its capricious it's a
crapshoot so that's why people settle so
much because you can lose and not win
all right I mean that's pretty simple
like if you could only lose and you
can't win maybe you should pay a few
bucks to get out of it we select okay
why do you sell that lawsuit so on the
financial crisis itself so I should make
clear you know the regulates did a lot
of good things okay Lehman Brothers
would not happen today
Lehman would have had two and a half
times as much equity three times as much
liquidity two times as much long-term
debt the regulator's have the legal
authority to take it over now which they
did not have in 2008 and they have the
knowledge to manage it think of an
orderly management of a bankrupt company
as opposed to at your fire everybody and
for a financial company you want an
orderly liquidation over time cause
they're not dumping assets in the
marketplace that's all been fixed and
even if it went bankrupt which wouldn't
happen that the second of bankruptcy all
that debt would become equity so like
120 billion dollars that would be come
back with your beacon the most over
equities France company in the world all
the derivative contracts are stay in
place they should take a victory lap and
so though and those were important to do
and I think someone's now of course some
of it was overdone and it needs to be
recalibrated but and they're things
which I think damage like one of the
ones and you could put this on the
negative productivity list
I should be lengthen this less a little
bit mortgages the there are 3,000 to
send you a bill and you know there are
3,000 requirements now and different in
50 states we should have national laws
and because of that it's really
expensive servers in mortgage who pays
for that
the customer ultimately and then also
origination requirements the same thing
anyone that kind of mortgage recently
it's torture you know and and who pays
for that
and because the cost is higher what
happens to mortgage availability it
drops and then because of litigation
stuff a lot of the big company the
bank's pretty much got out of some
things so who got less more availability
a young immigrant self employed prior
default the mortgages between 200,000
and 300,000 and you see it dead in all
the numbers and that one thing alone are
Aconitum ated that you could have had
you know three or four hundred million
more mortgage a year to last five years
that's a trillion five net new mortgages
that's a lot of homes and some that have
been new homes and so you know we did
that to ourselves and we should say I
don't know what this change of tomorrow
now the government is aware of this and
you know the wheels of regulate
regulations are moving baby fixed that
would be good for America and it does
not add any risk the people who owned
that insured etc it will be fine our
friend Peter Wallison stepped out right
before the sands oh yeah he knows it's
better than any well he's yet no he
really he he knows it well and and I
think he agrees with every work who's
next
next hand up yes sir playful tone up in
the front row hey clay fuller I'm a Jean
Kirkpatrick fellow and foreign and
defense policy studies here at at AI
with increasing money laundering
scandals going on around the world I'm
wondering if you have a comment on the
use of anonymous shell companies and
beneficial ownership reg registries and
how that works and as it applies a
higher compliance cost to banks and
specifically whether that should be
shared that cost should be shared more
with the lawyers the Realtors and the
other accountants that set up some of
these money-laundering avenues for
sanctions individuals another thing we
can fix this okay
so the cost is enormous and then we
torture the clients kyc files documents
every subsidiary the officers the rights
and it goes through you know every time
you swipe that card every time we move
money it goes from 50 70 hundred maybe a
thousand algorithms makes her safe and
we do this with with with companies and
who are they and there's a money
laundering and did the small business
grow too fast is it too much cash how
come they did this and and so if you
have a hair keeping shop and you went
from 800,000 to a million six of
additional revenues and was all as extra
cash that would trigger stuff okay so
and anything gets triggered that
histories things we report to the
government is called czars
I'd rather stands for it but it's
basically we have a suspicious activity
report they get to or thousand-year from
us and probably 2 million a year from
everybody but the banks can't share it
with each other I don't know why not
like the government
I'll share it the laws are written in
such a way that we create huge
bureaucracy around it so I think you can
actually this is great oh you can
capture more bad guys and reduce the
cost in the system and by some countries
in the United States one of the biggest
things in you mentions kyc all these
shell companies in some countries when
you file a corporation you have to state
the ownership period you're done with
that one major issue here you know you
have to invest company after company
after company and god forbid you make a
mistake the penalties so obviously all
the banks want to do this really well we
don't want to help terrorists and money
launderers and every now and then
someone's gonna slip through the system
but there are better ways to do it again
the government is working in this and
but it's just another one of those
things we just don't get right another
thing on the list all right right here
ma'am and then we'll uh Mike's coming to
you thanks thank you for all the
comments we're back our bagasse from a
head of global public policy for Comcast
NBC one of the issues that's but
deviling all of us is issues of security
and privacy that are you know just in
the pages every day if you were king for
the day and could do something that
would actually get executed what would
you do to address those it's a huge
problem not news biggest cyber I mean we
we are we are we spent several million
dollars in cyber
we're very protected but our country is
not and again the government knows this
but they got to move faster privacy is a
huge deal and so it's very simple in
this one to say what the principle
should be the principal and the in
Europe did this goes GPD our laws that
the customer should know what
information have in them and that they
should have the right effectively to
delete it and those principles sound
great but in reality the execution of
policy but it'd be really carefully
right that because it's really hard to
show these people have 400,000 data
points on you how do you even show it to
a customer if you say delete so I had to
be any you could disk I may delete if I
gave it to Jackie already and who gave
it to so-and-so now you couldn't build
technology that if I delete it delete it
and Jackie's can
at least on his computer so all these
things to be done it's got to be really
really careful so the fundamental
principle be easy I think the American
public when they find out the truth is
will be outraged I don't think when
people say that they don't care I don't
think they know and I think you know
usually the young kids the Millennials
and stuff they don't pay attention this
kind of stuff until later in life you
know and then they're gonna pay more
attention to it I'll just make a side
note Millennials because I hear they're
depressed you know they're not gonna get
ahead as much as we all get ahead the
GDP of America even would grow slow okay
he's gonna double in the next 30 years
out a bridge household average GP or
person 65,000 3,000 when all of our
great-grandparents came to this nation
where do they inherit nothing
what's this generation can inherit a
nation worth 150 trillion dollars today
is theirs for the giving could we all be
gone the millennia don't still be
complaining so but there are there are
requirements so like you you can say
that if you were advertising truth in
advertising you know so you guys have to
follow to it and advertising a lot of
their social media doesn't you could say
you have to for JP Morgan I do business
to you I have to verify you so some of
these people posted some noxious stuff
why don't we have required that be
verified so you can go on Twitter or
Facebook now and you're gonna probably
get tons of Jamie diamonds I'm not on
Facebook or Twitter you know and God
knows what they're saying so I think
there are and I if I was the folks and
I'm a little sympathetic to the folks of
Silicon Valley but if I was them I was
realized I have a real problem and they
are in inning two and and this any and
the other thing which I've learned in my
long life when problems start okay that
letter is a letter to every AG of every
state to the DOJ to the SEC to the FCC
to all the foreign regulators so in when
it starts man it just it should all come
at the same time but okay who's next
yeah right here on the edge hi I'm a
reporter for S&P global market
intelligence um I don't blame you
that could mean anything right so I want
to ask you is the era of too-big-to-fail
over now that you said that that our
system financial system is safer
regulators have done their job what are
your thoughts well firstly you're gonna
have a recession one day you're gonna
have a crisis one day it'll be different
than last crisis and I'm not saying cuz
I want it if by too big to fail and you
have to define that cuz most people
don't know what that means but if by too
big to fail means that if you fail the
Gummer's got to bail you out then yeah
we were mostly done and then they can't
unwind you because big comes will fail
can they do it in a way that doesn't
hurt you and that the taxpayers not
gonna pay that's been done all of the
money that's been paid out of the FDIC
was funded by the banks JP Morgan alone
has put ten billion dollars the FDIC to
pay for failure of small banks okay so
the the way was set up which is the
right way by the way if there's a
failure and and the FDIC has pay any
money they will charge it back to the
Romanian banks so I think it's mostly
over but you should always be on the
lookout for things that can cause
problems in the system things that you
know that governments good only
governments can do you know business
can't do it's a cyber might be one of
them and not just for us it could be
cyber for multiple industries out there
so uh yeah it's over and the issue now
you know you don't see the big banks
total meth or not dodd-frank and
reversing anything there were 2000 rules
a lot of these rules have calibrations
and all with all this needs to done is
coordinate and calibrate in the way that
makes sense for the economy that's all
not to make banks so they can fill again
we have time for one more question and
then I'm gonna send you all back to make
a living here in the back hi Jeff
Seabrook you with Walmart's public
policy team here in DC proud Chicago and
I remember taking checks my dad's
business would have to first Chicago
then bank one and then two you know the
bank today can you tell us a little bit
about you know when people think about
banking they're thinking about New York
they're thinking about the financial
centers around the world is inherently a
global kind of element but in that time
than when you came back to Chicago and
Bank wanted some of the perspectives and
lessons you've learned there and
kind of how that kind of created the
bank today but you know basically we're
one of the things about banks I think
it's sometimes a complicated thing
unlike Walmart when someone walks into
Walmart and have money you saw them a
good banks have a other job to do which
is proper allocation of capital half the
time people ask for some we say no that
kind of pisses people off it could be a
credit card even we make a loan to a
company you know covenants it's kind of
like okay you know you have to sell your
Ferrari
no we we discipline but you need
discipline capital undisciplined
capitals would caused the crisis
undisciplined capital like countries
don't grow and the capital markets in
general discipline so don't think it is
the bank the capital markets investors
hedge funds activists it's all part of a
discipline to get capital properly
allocated but my job is the same as
yours and I think you guys are
exceptional company which is to serve
this to make clients happy on every
interaction so the people think banks
are mystical but they're not and they're
consumer we take your money and then you
could spend it with a credit card debit
card check card we give you alerts we do
online bill pay we just rolled out if
you're a good customer free trading of
stocks and bonds all right to hear that
free I mean and and so we want to
enhance that experience all the time so
we're always in the incident know for
the corporations we make loans we move
money we raise equity of debt and the
one that scares the hell people it
really shouldn't is interest rate you
know it's derivatives but 85% are
interest rates and FX having people like
you manage your business all the time I
think our average revenue in FX trade is
$75 we just do a lot of them and we try
to manage the risk and stuff like that
so our job is to serve the client and
manage the risk most or risk eight when
they took a risk taken America it sounds
like yeah whoo let's go for this if you
walked into my office and said we're
gonna we think rates going up rates
going down this document gonna be done I
don't care that's not a business okay
it's what a business is serving you and
then managing the residual exposure so
we might do a huge loan for you in five
countries and then we quickly syndicated
so we can reduce our risk and broaden it
out and stuff like that but the end of
the day the job is serve a client so I
will the country and you know their
clients we their countries we held up in
the crisis so go back to too big to fail
you should ask
Canada what we did to help them with the
housing crisis and you should ask a lot
of clients I got a note from a little
company of the day reminding me that I
told the guy call whenever you have a
big problem he called me late in oh
eight and all his banks were billing and
we made the whole loan okay and you can
ask tons of companies that we tried to
do the right things and to be there
importantly in through thick or thin and
the best thing you need to be there in
bad times because you guys need us in
bare times you know good times you
barely need us a basis point but when
the things get tough you know your banks
got to be there and banks didn't change
the price but just keep this in mind so
banks world goes the healthy ones the
only healthy ones couldn't rolled over
trillions of dollars of loans trillions
in Oh 8 and oh nine we rolled over
ourselves a trillion to middle-market
small business large corporations at the
ongoing price like LIBOR plus 125 or
even your bonds were probably training
the marketplace at LIBOR plus 500 if you
could sell them but you would have
considered that rapacious if we did that
and so we don't do that we just wanted
to try to keep people alive so it's
basically the same job you move money
invest money hold money lend money get
your money and we try to do it well we
we move six trillion dollars around the
world every day and we try to do it and
we do it very safely very effectively
and very low cost
don't let the Silicon Valley so my
friends and you in the past hour you've
had common sense policy lessons lessons
on positive ethical leadership and a
whole lot of entertainment jamie dimon
thank you always a pleasure thank you
very much
[Applause]